Hello. Hello. Hello.
How are you, Caleb? I'm good. Thanks, mate.
Raring to go.
So
today,
you very kindly offered to join me,
and we are going to take a crack
at
modernizing PHP development using Docker, Docker Compose, and
Kubernetes.
Yeah. I'm excited because I've seen a few
different ways of doing it,
and I want to hear your way.
Well so,
I mean, the confession here is the last
time I wrote a line of PHP was
probably in 2016.
However
Still the same. I'm good on the Docker
stuff. Right? So Yeah. Like, between us, we
we we we got this. I'm sure. So
do you just wanted to do a quick
introduction? You happy to do that for thirty
seconds?
Hello, everyone. I'm Kieran. I'm primarily a software
developer,
so I'm less of an ops person.
I do a lot of consulting,
lot of TDD and BDD stuff, lot of
agile stuff.
And I've I've kind of avoided
caring too much about where stuff gets deployed
until the last few years.
And I think I've got a decent Docker
knowledge.
I'm terrible at orchestration.
So it may lose me towards the end,
but I can I'm sort of up on
containers,
and someone else takes care of that other
stuff
a lot of the time.
I guess that's right. One of the things
about Docker is that
even if you're just a software person,
right, you're having to understand how these things
work because it's maybe how you're running it
locally as well.
It's it's Yeah. And I I think that's
that's really important. I think that what we're
gonna look at today is is how do
we use these tools
to make this local development process
better.
But then, you know, get it that, you
know, the last mile as well and so
it's something like Kubernetes or any container based
deployment really. But we're we're focused on Kubernetes.
Yeah.
And I'm not too worried about my lack
of PHP knowledge because when see, when it
comes to container based development, there's only two
ways to go. There's dynamic and interpreted languages,
and then there's compiled languages.
Like, that's it. Like, there's only two workflows,
and I don't I've never seen a runtime
or a language or a framework where that
changes beyond those two dynamics. So Yeah. I'm
pretty confident. I think in a typical PHP
project, you also have to understand it's
likely to also be a JavaScript project.
So something that people find difficult is that
they're having to manage those two separate build
pipelines
and and, yeah, have the interrupt.
You know, I never
even gave that a moment's thought.
So
if that comes up, we'll tackle it one
step at a time. Yeah. That's just from
my experience of, you know, here's a nice
PHP deployment pipeline, and someone says, well, how
do I get my webpack stuff into that
as well?
Because I've got to transpile all this TypeScript
I've written, and you kind of
shrug your shoulders if you're a PHP person.
Yeah. We'll we'll we'll do our best to
tackle that too. Because that's more like a
compile
pipeline style. Right?
Well, yeah. It it has a belt step
to, you know, generate some assets that need
to be consumed from the actual web server
side of things.
I think, actually, it would be really cool
to cover that because one of the things
we're gonna focus on today is a split
between the PHP code being interpreted by PHP
FBM
and
engine x actually running as the web server.
So, you know, been able to deliver those
static access into the engine x server,
then just have the PHP code be delivered
from PHP.
Depending on how this works, like, kinda haven't
read PHP in a long time, but we
could do we could easily go the other
way and have PHP, FPM deliver those static
assets too. So I think where your wonderful
judgment is gonna have to keep me right
on what is best practice at PHP lab.
And so the question that comes up lots
and lots in
PHP in PHP land when you're doing Docker
is because PHP isn't a web server. FPM
isn't a web server.
Typically, people are using NGINX and FPM.
And so the obvious question
that every Slack and every IOC channel has
is, should I put them in the one
container,
or should I have two I
know you've got an opinion.
Last time I I do.
Do definitely have an opinion. So I'm gonna
share my screen right away because I
have tackled this question
before.
I give a talk in 2018. In fact,
I've given this talk many, many times. I'm
sure it
I think you've seen it on one on
one occasion, but it's my kick ass development
environments with Docker talk.
I gave this talk from 2016
to 2018. The one that's got the most
traction and questions is this one from LaraCon
to be in such a large event.
But and this talk, what I said to
people was, you know, always deploy them separately.
Always deploy NGINX and FPM separately.
Mhmm. And it's important to know that, well,
Kubernetes was definitely
probably still the default container orchestration tool in
production in 2018, this talk focused purely on
local development, nothing else. And what I suggest
that people do is to use a Docker
a Docker option which allows you to consume
the volumes from one container and another container,
which meant that you could have engine x
consume
all of the code volume from the APM
container,
and you didn't have to worry about the
fails not exist on the engine x container.
Because that's the biggest problem. Right? People say,
oh, I need things on engine x because
engine x has to know that fail exists.
You
does it need to know about the PHP
files?
It doesn't. No. So It's the other came
out. Right? It's the
So that's what I wanna show today exactly.
The engine access doesn't care if those files
exist or not. It can forward them without
doing any local checks.
So where the volume's from option and the
talk is is still very much valid and
you can use that local development, it falls
flat when you go to production. Very difficult
to have a volume with your code being
orchestrated on multiple nodes and are consumed for
token damage. So
we're we're just gonna promote the idea that
NGINX doesn't care and doesn't need to care
about that. And one of the questions I
get all the time or just at the
bottom of the thread are,
you have an example of how I do
this today? People who want to see this
they they want the quote. Right? They don't
wanna have to write this themselves.
And that's our plan. And we're gonna provide
a quote for people to do this without
having to constantly questions and comments on this
review.
With that in mind, I have gone ahead
and created a PHP examples repository
on get labs slash Rawkode slash PHP hyphen
examples.
I will synchronize it to GitHub later, but
for now, this is where it's gonna live.
Mhmm. And I haven't checked it locally, and
assuming our setup is
working nicely,
you should have the ability to take the
take the take the somewhere in the file.
It's it's loading. It's
Okay.
Well, it's not important. Might be saturating my
bandwidth.
But you can always see what I'm typing.
We can try and pair program program it
up, and if we really need to, we'll
refresh your staff.
Okay.
Yeah. It does work.
Okay. Let me try typing something.
Oh, there we go. You're there in my
file. Hello? Perfect.
So I'll
I kind of I've only added some readmeets
right now so that I could push this
repository.
Mhmm. So the plan being that we'll cover
using Docker Docker Compose for local development,
cover the last mile of getting into Kubernetes,
tackle any pain points and pitfalls as we
go.
You're gonna keep me right on everything that
you have inside of your head, and I
will do my best to
describe everything that I'm doing as we go.
Now my plan
sleep after that, won't worry.
So it's
to use Slim framework.
I'm now doubting that decision already because I
don't think that Slim
has that
node JS dependency
build step, and maybe it's better to do
something a bit more feature complete or at
least has all those steps for us to
to deal with. What are your thoughts?
I don't have a strong preference which framework.
I I'm not an expert in how to
build web assets. I'm regretting making it kind
of, but we could do something in slim
and just add a little
transpile step to something.
Or we could just talk about it.
No. Okay. We'll continue with the plan. We'll
just it's definitely easier if get a PHP
web framework going that I'm familiar with. We
can very easily add, like, a package dot
JSON,
fill in some random load dependency and have
it spell an asset. Right? And I'm okay
with that. Yeah.
Okay.
Which means that what we have to do
is create a new slim framework application.
So how do I do that?
Do you just install it with Composer
and make an index PHP?
Something along those lines? Yep. So according to
their documentation, we do Composer
space create type of project.
We then have slim, some skeleton, dev, master,
the final parameter of some app name.
Yeah.
I mean, I just wanna put it in
a local directory. Hopefully, it still does that.
But we were calling this Docker
Kubernetes.
Yeah. That should be fine. We
They're saying it's not empty, but that's okay.
Workforce.
I don't see a
I'm just gonna type force.
I think it won't install into an existing
folder.
Oh, it won't. Well
You just make another copy
of the README.
Yeah. Yeah. Oh,
oh, I just
I'm sure I just put my README over
the other README. Anyway, not bad.
So let's try that again. Create our projects.
Does it go Oh, I'm not in the
right directory. That's right.
Let's go and say Docker and Kubernetes, but
move root meaning itself, destroying it for r
dot n d.
I want the composure.
Mhmm.
Create project
Docker.
We'll get there.
It's better to have these challenges and model
slip ups at the start because then it
means nothing goes wrong there.
Are you on Composer two?
I have no idea. Composer doesn't even exist
on this machine until about ten minutes ago.
It's
a little bit faster.
Maybe if we use Composer in the build
step, we can use too
in the doc.
But it's I just did a brew install
composer. I'm assuming a composer too is is
released and not in an RC stage or
anything like that, then I would probably
It's a beta stage, but, you know,
it's not run time of code, so it's
okay to use a beta.
Always.
I see that as I'm running on Mac
OS Big beta.
So what do you think? Big Sur has
some sort of fancy new virtualization framework built
into the OS. Do you think that's gonna
make Docker run fast?
So it does have APIs
for,
you know, tools to talk up for Mac
and
other stuff.
Think we're APNs, vagrant.
It's not something that I've I've tried yet,
because I don't think anything that I've installed
works with it at the moment. I'm really
hoping though that whatever they've configured to to
file synchronization has to be an improvement on
what we have right now. Like, for dynamic
interpretive languages, the fail sync from that Docker
for Mac is is the killer. Mhmm.
Yeah. It's just makes developing
any sizable project very, very slow.
Yeah.
Okay. So
what's this prompt? Do I do I want
to remove the existing
get history?
No?
Okay. I've not seen that before. It's interesting.
I guess it's just because I have
stuff going on here. Not really sure.
So let's see. What have I got here?
Oh, well, it did create me a new
directory.
Let's just move on to that.
K. Perfect.
So
we have a computer a composer JSON file.
With a bunch of stuff.
Look at that. It gives us a Docker
Compose file.
That's a bit too fancy, isn't it?
That's a
so it's using Alpine.
It is. So it's a working directory,
mixing command and entry point together.
It's even using the Rawkode approved environment, so
it'll send text. I I I really hate
it when people use the the less syntax.
Do that. Like, it just
why would we do this to ourselves?
Have to run for another day. We it's
supposed to pour, and we have volumes. I
mean,
it's pretty sensible for me. I'm not we're
making too many changes. There are a few
things in the three point x spec or
in the Compose spec that I don't like.
We may drop that down to two for
very good reasons.
We'll touch on them if
we make an up for it.
So What? Let's just There you go. Just
explain one thing to me. What is that
a good practice to be running PHP as
the entry point?
So this is That's not a good web
server.
For local dev, I think it's it's it's
fine.
I don't really have any problems with it.
It does mean that our development environment doesn't
have any sort of parity with our production
environment. So, you know, there may be things
to that, like, you know, that's had an
HD access in this public folder. Like, that's
not gonna do anything on that and and
your next environment for Yeah. Yeah. For example.
So you may find that if you're using
the HD access for any sort of security
concerns or
redirects,
anything like that, that that discrepancy between production
and development, if it's just frustrating, I probably
would avoid it. But I can see why
they're doing it. They're just trying to avoid
any additional complexity.
I'm
actually surprised how much stuff there is considering
slim is haven't made a slim project in
a while.
Slim is high grade cut down framework.
They've got Travis setup and
all sorts.
Yeah. ADR directory style structures.
It's
not the slim framework I remember from 2015.
That's for sure.
Alright.
Let's just
test this works locally and get it working
in Docker. Does that sound
sensible to you? Would you
would you be more specific about the version
of PHP?
Okay. So you're talking about using seven dash
Alpine instead of seven dot one dash Alpine?
Or seven four maybe.
Or 73. Sorry.
I'm I'm trying my best here. Yeah. Yeah.
Exactly.
Would I would I specify a point version?
I think very possibly.
I mean, I don't pay a lot of
attention to the PHP RFCs anymore. But I
do believe they make a lot of changes.
Is Versus Code saying that you wrote that
line?
You know, you were surprised Did I add
this?
Four years ago. I did.
So all these criticisms are criticisms of you.
No. See, I I don't think I added
this. Hold on. Oh, hold on. Hold on.
Slamming this Docker Compose file, and it's your
work. I wasn't slamming it. Let's
see. Let's see. There must be a scan.
Perfect.
Well, we've got a couple of comments. So
let's just see what's going on. We've got
one here that says,
if we go with Laravel, then Laravel next
ships with some JavaScript stuff. So,
definitely, we I will provide a Laravel example
either in this session or just after this
session. We'll see how things go.
We got Glenn asking how late you are.
You're not late. We're just starting. We've not
done anything of use for anyone.
And we have our friend, Bastian, who's tuning
in. Nice to see you too.
Hi, Bastian.
So
let's get into you're a slim contributor.
Yeah. That's me.
How much am I so far?
Yeah. So someone modified this version. I'll have
worked with that.
That's that's not fair. This is just
let me cover the the version in more
detail before we get started then. So when
Docker promoted the Compose spec, the three point
x,
they really targeted people that wanted to then
go from
global development to production.
So they added all of these extra parameters
or pragmas, whatever you wanna call them, that
allowed you to then use the same Docker
Compose file to generate a Docker bundle, which
could be deployed on Docker Swan.
Yeah.
They eventually added Kubernetes stuff on top of
that. I can't remember the exact version, 3.4,
three point five, whatever it was, which means
you can now just deploy that Docker bundle
or the Compose file straight for Kubernetes.
The challenge is is that where we want
parity between Docker between development and production
is that there are some very key changes
in the way that you work from a
workflow perspective that just don't translate. Like, on
a a Kubernetes environment, I don't care about
the order of containers start and the container
may be deployed
at their own way with their own CI
and CD pipeline.
Local development, I very much care about the
order and the way the thing was started
because I may have the database migrations to
run. I need the database server to be
healthy. I've got web pack steps that are
really important. There's all of these things that
need to be coordinated.
Two point x specs makes that really easy
to do through very sophisticated health checks.
So we probably will drop that version down,
and that's why. And we can maybe show
why it's painful first, and then jump back
and say, that is why you should just
use two point o. And I've
heard the argument that the health checks
should be part of your
your application,
be part of your system,
and not the responsibility of the orchestration tool.
If
you if I'm writing a worker that's gonna
read for from a queue,
I've got two options, haven't I? Either I
can write my code assuming the queue's there
and kind of outsource that readiness.
Or I can write my application so it's
gonna have some sort of retry
as part of my code of my worker.
Where do you fall on that?
So I do agree that your application has
to be built with that resiliency factor in
mind, and that if things do go wrong,
it will retry it. Of course. That makes
sense to me.
But, again, spinning up something in local development
is just that bootstrapping phase is so unique
and so different that I just think it's
really important. Like, when I start my application,
I really want to build code that retries
my migration path
until it works. Yeah. I mean, no.
And when I go to production, I want
that if that migration step fails, I want
an error log, and I want something to
say, hey. This is this is not working.
I don't want it to just silently keep
me trying without giving me any indicators that
something's potentially wrong.
Yeah. So
And I guess on production, you're not doing
a cold start very often of all your
services together.
Yeah. Only once, but you spin up a
new cluster or something. So And on dev,
if one of your services falls over,
you probably stop everything and start it all
again.
I am
a serial destroyer and recreator of the world.
I like to do that frequently. I like
to do it often, and I like to
make sure that our mission works. Yep.
Definitely.
So is that tricky so this leads us
to using Docker Compose.
But there's a kind of
what what is what are the downsides of
that? It means you
don't quite know it's gonna work until you
deploy to some Kubernetes environment?
With most of the
control,
it's less you're not dog feeding it as
much.
I just
you get a very limited amount of the
features of Kubernetes available to you when you
go through the Compose file using that as
the the description of your Kubernetes deployment. The
department where I'd say, you're really just using
the wrong tool for the job.
And you should just be using a Kubernetes
manifest and getting familiar with working with that
because,
you know, even if your application is a
monolithic PHP application, there's still surrounding services that
you need to deploy. And I don't think
the Compose file is a good way to
describe that for all of the environments. Mhmm.
Especially, again, the database I'm gonna keep hammering
on about. But my production deployment of a
database does not look like my development deployment
of database.
And, yeah, there are Docker Compose overlays of
the ability to extend service definitions per environment.
But then we're just gonna answer this really
convoluted setup that I don't think is actually
going to save you any time in the
long run. That is probably just gonna slow
you down and cause a little bit of
chaos.
Yeah. And and looking forward, I think
the idea a lot of the supporting infrastructure
like databases and queues and things, the trend
seems to be away from running them yourself.
I don't know if that's your experience. So
No. You're completely right. My my Docker Compose
locally is gonna be running a MySQL instance
or or whatever.
But in prod, maybe I'm using Aurora serverless
or
some other
I know MySQL is not the best database,
but you know what I mean.
Exactly.
You know, when we're deploying things into Azure,
AWS, or even GCP, all those managed services
become really, really appealing and that we don't
have to handle the complicated state inside of
our applications anymore.
So maybe only
deploying the web the FPM service and Extremely
likely. Exactly.
Alright. Let's let's get started then. So
yes. That turns out I contributed this Compose
file. I have no idea.
But
that's not important. Good catch. I had never
noticed that.
So that looks like That
line has not even changed in four years.
That's still just PHP seven all time. Like
So can you recap what the Docker true
environment variable is for?
No.
I'm
not sure what this is for. So it's
been four years, Kevin.
Yeah. I'm assuming there's something in the configuration
of this application.
Alright.
Tap here. Found it right. There we go.
So and
yeah. Perfect.
I'm assuming I didn't add that too.
So if it's in the Docker environment,
it logs to logs to standard. Yeah.
Why does Compose file have a logs
volume?
Adverse here. It might not be being used
then
in Docker. Very
possibly. It could be
that.
Yeah. I don't know. Let's find out. Let's
get it working.
Let's get it working.
So
I'm surprised I have contributed to the rest
repository because there's no make fail.
The
big argument against that is Windows doesn't ship
with Make.
That's why Symphony ended up not using Make
after
very nearly adopting it as the recommended way
of doing things.
But sure, though, I mean,
that's the time to change it. I don't
wanna get into the whole WSL too and
when it was being a really good dev
machine now, but make us available.
It's not on your terminal. Anyway so
how do I run this? I do PHP
then
no. No. That's
a thing. Right?
For you do docker Well,
I just wanna run it locally first.
PHP dash s.
I'm assuming
Composer has tasks. Right?
Yeah. They're called scripts.
Scripts. So I can just click Composer star?
That work? Yep.
Alright. And if I go to here,
it it it.
Right.
It
works. It's a good site.
Where did it log to? Did you see
any logs? I was about to check. No.
So when you were there some in the
terminal?
Yeah. They were. Yeah.
That's the web service logs.
That's not the Oh, yeah. The Well, so
because it's the same thing. Right? Oh, no.
The application. Okay. Definitely. Because it's got us
on longer. Okay. Maybe it's not working.
So assuming I haven't made this the worst
Docker Compose file in the world four years
ago,
I should.
That
takes a while.
It just eats so much bath today that
you've gotta close it when you're not using
it right. Yeah.
I kinda want a script that
wraps Docker
and starts it.
If it's not started, if you see what
I mean.
I think that would be good. Starting on
the
I mean, I'm not gonna do it right
now, but I don't think it would be
How how much stuff is in the vendor
folder while while that's while that's pulling?
It's quite a lot of stuff, isn't it?
Yeah.
I'm not I'm not sure if that's a
lot. I mean, I've been working on some
node projects lately, so this is this looks
quite slim,
Kinda intended. That's what we mapped, isn't it?
Yeah.
So, you know, we could do a fail
account here and see how many fails we're
actually dealing with. I found that anything above
usually 4,000, but thanks to that.
Let's see. So this is running,
so we should be able to refresh.
We're still good.
What was the page load time? Just out
of interest.
Can you
Can
there. Or does it tell me that here?
Hello.
Go to network. And
we're at
three hundred and fifty milliseconds for Hello World.
That's pretty slow.
How about that faster?
It's it
is slow, but it's okay.
If you're if you're a developer looking at
a site in a browser, it's usable, isn't
it?
Okay. So
what we wanna do, first and foremost, is
remove
the PHP web server, and we wanna bring
in FPN
and NGINX.
Yeah.
That's two separate containers. Right? That's two separate
containers. That is that is the question that
we can ask for the example of. So
that will be the first thing we tackle.
So
It's
formatting. Oh, there's no header. I'm thinking this.
Slime is letting me down. So
Yeah.
I am a tab person, just for the
record, but I've got so fed up of
facing it.
It was just the world has gone. Space
is crazy.
Shouldn't you be setting the indent size just
for YAML?
Because everything else is full.
Yeah. No. I think that's the right thing.
K.
We just called this podcast. How to get
attracted by every trivial detail before without actually
doing any rework.
Sorry. No. That's not I
thought that would work. It didn't let's just
do yeah. I know this. We'll keep an
agent. I'll do it over there. There we
go.
We're adding NGINX.
It's an image. Why do we need NGINX?
It's because
FPM itself isn't gonna be able to respond
to web requests
because it doesn't have an HTTP interface.
Yeah. So to the best of my knowledge,
APM
is
just processes the PHP and it takes requests
in over a socket and sped something back
over a socket, but doesn't actually deliver any
web server functionality. Right? Yes. Even the fast
CGI
connection is how I understand it.
So it
doesn't have an HTTP
web server built in.
And that's maybe a historical
thing. Right? Because
because normally you'd have NGINX and FPM on
one box.
Or you'd have a Mod Apache in the
old days.
So it didn't feel wrong having these two
daemons running that are gonna just to do
one thing.
Maybe that's where the question comes up a
lot. When you go into Docker world, you've
got this
ideology
that you should just have one one process
per container.
But then you need two containers to do
one thing, which feels
wrong. That's that's yeah. So in a Docker
environment,
you do need
you you should always have one process per
container, and and you do need two containers
to run a PHP application.
That
when it moves to Kubernetes, though, it starts
to leverage something called the pod, which understands
that there should be multiple containers there. Right.
But it's a much it's a much better
fit in the Kubernetes kinda landscape. But, yeah,
for Docker, Docker Compose, it can feel a
little bit counterintuitive.
But,
again, talking about parity between development and production,
we we really do want to isolate these
things. And they they both have very different
properties. NGINX, we just want to deliver static
assets. FPM, we just want to run it
through.
And the challenge of running both of those
in the one container is
how would you rate a health check for
a container with multiple pool service?
If FPM dies and engine x is still
healthy, is that container good?
If engine x dies and FPM is still
running, is that container good? Like and you
don't want to start writing health checks or
checking for multiple sockets being open and checking
that they're both valid and it's Yeah. Very
much work.
I guess health checks are kind of second
line of defense, aren't they? The the first
health check for a container is is is
it still running?
Like and and if you can make it
so that the as long as the main
process is running, the container's fine.
You don't have to worry as much about
health checks.
Yep. I think we're good that. That's because
I know why
I've seen people running supervisor d
as their entry point
Yeah. Or running lots of workers
or, you know, system d.
If if you're running a supervisor in your
container, that is no. Actually,
see, this is where this this is little
tiny bit of nuance. It's like, there is
a very good use case for running a
supervisor. Usually, it's tiny inside the Docker Compose.
But we're gonna ignore that for now. If
you run a supervisor in the container, there's
too much going on. Just use a VM.
Use Vagrant. Yeah. Just go down that approach
and Mhmm. Yeah.
If you're if you're running an entry point
that you know is something designed never to
die,
it doesn't tell you about the health of
the system.
K.
Alright. So you check again. Let's let's let's
do this. Valuable information, I think. These are
good things.
So we okay. So what have I done?
I've added NGINX. I have used an NGINX
image. I'm not gonna involve a tag right
now. I'm not that flexible with bears, not
it. I'm exposing this on port eighty eighty
now, which means I need to remove eighty
eighty from FPM
even though it's not FPM yet.
And that's fine. We don't actually need FPM
to be exposed. We can remove an entire
attack vector here by not having the FPM
exposed to our customers or users.
So we need to move that way.
And I'm happy for that just to run
right now. Makes no difference to me. I'm
just gonna spin this back up, and what
we should see is we now have NGINX
PHP still running, but not serving any traffic
to it.
Yeah.
I can't remember what the default NGINX response
is. Is it page not found or something?
Probably.
Yeah. I think you get no. So the
NGINX container will deliver a high versus NGINX.
Oh, really? And yeah.
That should be relatively
smallish.
Yep.
So we do have slums are running,
and we have engine x. I refresh this
page.
Three milliseconds.
See, good numbers.
Alright.
Now we still want to deliver
our PHP application. So what I'm gonna do
is we're gonna move this over to FPM.
Is
there an FPM Alpine tag maybe?
Think there is
well, Alpine FPM.
Let's jump over to up docker.com/_/pt.
At the end. Okay.
Yeah. There does seem to be an update
variant.
How
does that run?
So let's just
grab the Docker file.
Unless you know it when you just wanna
tell me, but Has it for an entry
point
that
if you specify a command that's a PHP
command, it'll run it. Otherwise, it will start
FPM.
That's my understanding.
Alright. So this points off to
that should cost.
Right. So assuming we're doing four
Alpine
FPN.
Yeah. Runs that.
Well, it's not actually using the entry point
unless that's
I get it early.
So
f p m Fortnite thousand,
and what path is this expecting?
Think it's spelled w w w.
So I haven't worked there. Yeah. Part of
it, w h t m l. Okay. So
we're just gonna change this to match.
We don't need a command overwrite anymore. We're
happy with whatever's going on on the default.
As far as volumes go, we want our
code in the right location,
that has to be updated to
that.
That's okay?
Looks good to me.
Okay.
So
I'm gonna assume that's gonna work because if
I restart this, there's nothing for me to
verify that this works. What we need to
do now is tell NGINX how to proxy
the request to FPF.
And for this, we're gonna need a configuration
files, but I'm gonna create an opt directory.
NGINX inside of that,
my b host starts on.
Did you bring the engine x configuration with
you?
I've never
I've copy pasted it from project to project
and then got
someone to look at it for me. And
it kind of annoys me that I need
to do that.
So I think there's a gap in the
market for an
image that is just the NGINX
container with a sensible PHP
config?
Well,
after the Ladakhon talk, I had to push
this up.
Mhmm.
So
we're
just gonna grab this. This is what it
looks like. So we have the server definition
that runs on port 80.
This is using
app.
It's just naturally pass up
by any complication.
Yeah.
Our application is leveraged
from a public.
Yeah.
And this is the old way. So that
is the one where you would need to
share the volume. So I'm gonna leave that
and so that we can actually see that
there. Yep.
And then
yeah. Sorry. On you go? It comes from
the the model where your NGINX is also
gonna serve with your static assets. Right?
In the
because this is we
have to sort of see if the file
exists. Otherwise, we'll run it on PHP.
Yes. So what this is doing, it's saying,
if this URL doesn't exist, then pass it
as a parameter, I believe, through the PHP
so that we have this kind of single
entry point, and then the PHP application handles
the routing there.
We can change the configuration of that so
that it does the trial failed, but not
for PHP fails. And then for PHP fails,
regardless of exist about, just send it to
FPM and let it deal with it. Okay.
But I think I I don't even think
that's that sensible,
really.
Like, don't know if in production people do
scale their PHP NGINX.
Does the PHP NGINX have to be the
same as the static assets NGINX?
Maybe you'd want them to scale separately.
Or possibly, when you get to some point,
you're gonna use a CDN for your static
stuff, and this is only ever gonna serve
PHP.
Yeah. I think there's definitely a few caveats
there. I
probably wouldn't put down the route of having
my static assets to leverage from something that
wasn't delivering the PHP traffic because
from a customer perspective, they're heading the same
endpoint.
Well, it's a static asset or PHP file,
and I want that to be a one
single entry point and not do any complicated
routine there.
Also, just because I'm reading this,
this actually is set up to work. So
that's location.
But then we have this PHP filter which
passes at 10PM. So that's actually should work.
This this config is actually good.
So as expecting,
something could test on a DNS name of
PHP on port 9,000.
So if we just
change this from slim to PHP,
that should immediately work without me doing any
other changes.
Need On the other.
I to I can't even go. In the
right place.
Can you say that again, please? You need
to map the config file.
You are very correct.
Need a volumes,
and we need to take opsenginexbholes.com,
and we need to put this in
that may be right.
Let's double check that. So I I think
anything in conf d is okay.
Yeah. But there is a default virtual, and
I want to replace it to avoid that
configuration error. So if I do Docker container
l s,
definitely not bigger.
And
exec and stage,
I keep trying to
keep falling back in the
bad practice.
From bash,
Let's go take a look at comp.p.
So
we should be able to override that.
I I think
well, I wanna get to confident, but that
is enough.
But we're gonna stop everything
I'm patiently.
I'm just gonna back it.
Okay.
So if I pop back over here,
we have our PHP application. It's kinda getting
longer there. Five hundred and fifty eight milliseconds.
But it is being delivered
via engine x. Now we can confirm that
by doing
a.
That looks like a slim error.
Oh,
no. Okay. So that failed us. Okay. So
if we look at our virtual configuration,
and the failed does not exist. It goes
through index.PHP.
So
can we take that
hold it out?
That would mean that we would so we
could, definitely. It just means that our entry
point for this application would have to be
that.
What we can do is modify the Internet.
We we can drop something into that in
the next container. Right? So
just to show that it works, we don't
need to do anything else.
And so that would be six. Right?
Of course, it would be
that's the name.
We can go to w w w HTML.
That totally wasn't the path for the No.
That's that's correct. We didn't mount any of
the files into
NGINX.
So make it work for now.
You
can do a touch, even,
dot HTML.
And so Yeah. And
in theory,
we can now skip
this this could be a static asset, essentially.
And we can say
here.
Okay.
Few milliseconds.
Much faster. Mhmm. This is why p this
is why you don't want FPM delivering a
static asset. Mhmm.
Okay. Where is my code? So we're happy
with that. We're happy with that.
What's next?
Well, do wanna go into making a Docker
file?
Building the stuff?
Should we try and speed it up?
That's part of it. Build build the stuff
into the container so we're not don't have
to map as much stuff.
Yeah. So
the hypothesis
there is
changing your composer
dot JSON is a very rare activity. So
could we use Docker build caching
speed up that process?
Let's
tackle that when we do it. Yeah. We
so we are gonna add a Docker file,
and then we're gonna try and deploy that
to Kubernetes. I'm just wondering, is there any,
like, from a local dev point of view,
is there anything beyond this that you need?
Like, I can in fact, we haven't shown
one thing. Right? I can change the code
and then immediately I see
something happened. Right? So
I have no idea where that index page
is.
And you left the containers running, didn't you?
I did.
Is it action? User action? Is that the
default page?
Yeah. Maybe we should've used the framework one
of us knows.
Oh,
because I've created that directory with permissions,
haven't I?
I'm not sure what I've done there. Let's
fill up my logs.
I tried deleting the folder. That's all you
did, just touch that file.
Okay. So we're not getting an index now.
So
we don't actually want an index. What we
want is
go here.
Engine. Maybe try just taking the folder out
of the container the running container,
or kill the container and start it again.
That will definitely fix it. I'm just
alright. Okay. Yeah. We don't need to publish
the numbers.
You're right. We're all over.
Maybe we can. So that just says hello
world. So let's just search for that.
So it wasn't actually in any of those
things. It's in a roof tile. Okay.
So we should have real time development experience.
And, actually, I think with a project this
size, that is an acceptable
performance. You know, if you don't wanna get
too stuck into how Docker works and you
just want to
maybe run a really specific version of PHP
that you don't have you don't wanna install
locally, that's kind of
good enough.
Yeah. I'm not gonna get frustrated
making changes to that and and waiting for
it to reload. Yeah. Don't think I'm gonna
do it. That fast
when I'm developing. I'll make do some work
and then go over and check it sometimes
if I don't have a test.
I've seen devs on big Magento projects waiting
ten seconds for a page to load anyway.
Right.
Okay.
So local development, I think
we're okay on. The only thing we could
potentially modify now would be
ability to do you know what? That NGINX
thing is really bugging me. We're gonna make
that work. Okay. Because we're we're talking about
how we want NGINX to lower static assets.
And the minute I did that, I broke
it. You don't think we should fix that?
Sure.
The other thing I could look at is
how how would we use a database?
Yes.
I'm open to anything.
Do wanna what what was it that bothered
you about the NGINX? Is that when you
made the folder,
it no longer
looked at FPM?
Correct.
So
let's let's do let's do two things. First,
if you're watching and you want us to
cover any other thing that we've been talking
about, leave a comment, and we will make
sure that we tackle that. Right? What we'll
do for the next few minutes is we
will add that database component, and we will
revert Docker Compose down to version two, explaining
why that's important as we go.
Right? Because we we we do have a
migration step that we would want to run.
So
what's your favorite database?
Favorite or one I use the most?
Actually, the one you use the most, I
guess. MySQL.
Alright.
Yeah. I'm gonna use a Myriad DB version.
Oh, I don't know. Is Docker.
It's MySQL, but not one by by Oracle.
So Yeah. Yeah.
Oh,
we're kinda
weird flips there. Okay. So we're gonna run
MariaDB.
I think that it's starting as 10.
We've well explored this in my local machine.
I don't know why. But
Yeah. You want to run a MySQL client
in your ID or something at some point.
Right?
Yep.
And then we will set this down. Let's
spin this up. It'll kill the image. Nothing's
really changed, but it should just kinda make
work.
So sometimes I have two two Docker Compose
files. Right? One that adds
a load of exposed ports and extra
volumes and things that's explicitly dev.
Yes.
So,
yeah, I forgot for this. And we need
to tell the really be a a few
environment things. So we have to say,
my SQL password
password.
That should satisfy that.
We have a question from Glenn. He's just
curious
what does the Docker environment variable do. I
think Glenn, we're just a little bit late,
we'll cover that again.
This is
just a slam framework thing that tells it
to tweaks the logging to standard out. So
when you do container based development,
you always want the logs here, first and
foremost.
Even when you go to production, the logs
have to go to standard out because that's
how they're collected by
the d, the bit, any other logs dash
deal set.
And and instead of
settings,
it's just checking for that environment variable that
exists.
And if it does, it says, okay. We're
gonna log the standard out. Otherwise, it's gonna
log to the logs directory.
So it's just a slam framework thing.
I'm sure there's a way to configure that
for something in Largo too, but do examples
of that. Right? We're there tomorrow.
Now we should have
my sql MariaDB slash thingy working.
Yep.
Can you connect to And the challenge is
Have you got a local client you can
connect to it from?
Or command line? You
you trust your Internet connection?
It's pretty solid. I get about 500 meg.
What?
It's pretty good. Sorry. Not not megs because
we have the SI standards now.
Mebi bytes.
500 bytes. 500 Mebi bytes. It's
better than me.
I just have not gone green.
It's not according
to the message.
Alright.
It's only, which means it's not to user
local because it conflicts.
So you have to add it to the
path.
Okay. Camera's going crazy.
So we can do a post. Password.
Password.
Password. Okay.
But it's not a capital h for what's
done.
I like your
security
consciousness.
Do you you don't have MySQL installed locally,
do you? No. I do not.
What's lower h?
Let's do one two seven zero zero zero
one.
There.
User
I know. There we go. Nice.
Okay. So
that works. Now the the challenge with the
3.7 syntax now is that
we have very limited support
or depends on
All that's except
and the three point x spec is that.
What
that tells
our Docker engine
is
that it must start the MariaDB container first.
That's That is it. And that's so you
can do Docker up Docker Compose up PHP,
and it will also start the other guy.
Right?
Because so far, we've just been doing Docker
up.
Yeah. So it means when I run Docker
Compose up, that everyone will ensure that the
MariaDB container exists, but has not started or
health it exists and started, but not healthy
before it starts with PHP one. Now that's
important because the way that Docker Compose
handles
communication is generally through injecting stuff into the
host file,
and that name has to exist before that
container starts for it to work.
Mhmm.
So we could add NGINX there as well.
Right?
Yes.
Now the challenge is when my PHP entry
point is checking to the database to see
if it has to run a migration,
Is that MariaDB and most of our databases
do not start as quickly as FDM.
Databases generally take anywhere from two or three
seconds up to maybe a couple of minutes,
in worst case,
before they can actually start accepting queries or
rates to that system. Yeah. Which means that
we lose that wonderful ability of just typing
Docker Compose up and it working.
We then have to start adding make files
or batch scripts to do loads of checks.
And things get really complicated.
Some of the think when the database arrives
and then runs the migrations.
Yeah. When I see people time after time
I used to be a consultant, and every
company I would go to had this batch
scripts that tells the Docker log waiting for
some random arbitrary string that may or may
not change between versions of the database. That
somehow indicate that it is ready to receive
traffic.
Doing this is
okay. My equivalent is in the PHP.
Run the migrations,
catch the
MySQL connection isn't there yet, and then retry
it a few times.
So just try and run with migrations into
into the database until you get a success,
which is equal. Yeah.
Of course. I mean, you could do that
too with a restart policy of always and
just keep going and going and going and
going. But
and we then the restart become meaningless. Right?
We don't we wanna restart to me is
important. When a container exits, that means either
something needs fax, something crashed,
not that something wasn't available. And those to
me are very different finish scenarios that I'd
like to understand when I build an application.
In production,
you have things like Istio that
sort of hold your database connection until the
real database is there. And there's lot of
very sophisticated solutions around it.
But Yeah. So using a service mesh, which
is Istio in production, would allow you to
have automatic retries on that connection,
which means your application would just be and
it just looked like a really long request.
So then you're still susceptible to time outs
of the application or database takes longer than
that than full up. That's a good point.
And it's a really easy way. Like,
I mean, that's it. Like, we do that,
and then this would depend on syntax,
magically changing them to something that is actually
useful.
And so
version two is still supported. Right? It's still
current.
There's still Yeah. It's just they're just desperate.
I don't think there's been a new two
point x release in a while,
but with the open sourcing of the compose
let's cover a few details here.
Docker Compose.
Okay. It's back.
The best Compose spec website
only came out this year. And as Docker
is saying, right, we're we're gonna give up
control of the spec. I said, no no
longer something that we want to we want
to own.
It's not our IP. We make it available
to everyone. So now I
I do think that there
may be a new four point x that
is catered for dev and production and Right.
There may be changes that make this a
different situation.
But, unfortunately, for now,
is that Docker or Docker did still load
it. And what we've got here is 2.4
has been updated since, like, 2018,
not five, four.
And that's three point spec is continuing to
evolve, but it has all of that stuff
for production in it. So if we take
a look at
depends on
right. It's a very simple list where we
can specify the service.
However,
if we change
how do I get to it? Version two.
Then we can still have the list. Right?
So there's a there's
it works on both. But, however,
we have this more verbose syntax. Actually, it
allows us to say we're not just depending
on the service starting, but we actually want
to have a condition.
We will not start
a web application until a, our DB condition
is service healthy,
and Redis is condition service started.
And that's what we're gonna do here. So
What's the distinction with started and healthy? Started
just means it's been the boot started, but
it might not be ready, might not be
healthy.
Yes. So if we do NGINX conversion
service
started,
that's no different than doing that.
Those those are a problem.
So that's not gonna stop PHP in from
booting until NGINX has finished booting. It's just
gonna make sure NGINX starts up. Yeah. So
that's their primarily feature of the post naming
tests.
PHP will be able to resolve that somehow.
However,
for MariaDB,
that's not gonna hurt.
What we actually want is serve it,
help it. Yeah.
Unfortunately,
the last time I checked, MariaDB does not
ship with any health check instead of a
stock itself.
So we do excuse me.
We
do have to provide a health check,
and it's as simple as command,
and we can then
thank you for that. We can then use
any command within that container to establish whether
we think it's healthy or not. So if
we jump into our MySQL container,
anything we have available here can be a
help check on that. I am sure there's
probably
some MySQL thing we could use.
You could just try and connect.
Right?
Connect to the local host.
We could.
Don't wanna do it with the MyoScale command
because it will put me into some sort
of shell. So what we can do is
because this is batch, batch does some really
funky tricks around TCP
where we can actually do echo
Let's just say, hi,
dev.
Net.
I'm gonna get this wrong. 3306.
Yeah. It's gonna get it wrong.
Figure it.
That's good. That's good.
Actually had a problem once where
we the health check was trying to connect
internally in the MySQL
container,
and it was connecting, but it wasn't yet
accepting network
connections.
So it's it's accepting socket connections locally,
but it wasn't accepting
connections around through the through the ports. Ports
weren't exposed yet.
So it there we go.
So that's only works with bash. It doesn't
work with other shells,
which is okay if I'm really deep because
we have access to bash. But you can
see that if we try and echo anything,
they have TCP localhost and then the port
number as
batch will do a check to see if
that port is accepting any sort of traffic.
When we do three c o seven, a
port that we know doesn't exist, we get
this failure.
Because it's batch, we have an exit code
which is non veto, and we can use
that as a really rudimentary object.
Now we're doing that for quickness and kinda
speak right
now. But if we wanted to, we could
easily use something more sophisticated.
We probably could do a MySQL
port one
to seven.
That's root that password,
and then passing a query,
like,
databases.
Yeah. That would all be get on the
calendar that it was healthy. This is what
we're doing, but there's a problem with it.
It's like it'll
still use the local socket rather than the
network if it's present.
Something crazy like that.
So we found it unreliable, basically.
Yeah.
As my MariaDB and mySQL knowledge was just
a little bit better, I would go with
that approach because it gets me a more
holistic view of whether it's healthy or not
and not just a port being open.
But
it doesn't have to be perfect. So What
should happen with Meridian Meridian b should ship
ship with a health check. Right?
That would be the ideal solution.
The main thing I would want MariaDB to
ship with something that
allowed me to do my SQL test connection
like that. I know I I'm not a
big fan of health tech and system within
the Dockerfile.
I'm sorry. I do I do think we
should live as part of the Kubernetes manifest
or something else.
Or even in the Docker post file for
development because, again, my health checks in dev
and production are gonna be very different.
I
don't think they're always gonna be ubiquitous.
So we're MySQL just having some sort of
check, help, test command that ensures the database
is ready is ideally what I'd want to
see here. Yep.
Alright. For now, we're gonna do echo
f p two p, little so forth, p
p. And we're gonna make this fail to
show that it works.
But right now, this will never ever get
healthy.
Makes sense? Mhmm. Right.
Let's set an interval.
Run this every one second.
Boom.
Internal.
We're gonna spend all this time. Actually, I'm
just gonna destroy it. Everything
oh, no. It's not command. It is test.
Okay.
So we're gonna spin this up. Now what
should happen
I'm gonna spin this up in the background,
and then we're gonna run a Docker PS
and try and see if we can understand
what's going on. So
you can see it starts from really the
first, then into next,
and
our PHP container is not healthy.
I was just looking at the MariaDB documentation.
It says
it will not accept incoming connections until the
initialization completes. This may cause issues
when using tools like Docker Compose.
Great.
So they they're they're not shipping a health
check.
But that's good. The fact that they won't
accept that connection is how the database is
healthy means that our rudimentary
track on the port will actually be really
good. So Yeah. Yeah.
Good point. Now you can see I failed
to bring up the project. That's because
MariaDB
is still unhealthy,
and it cuts out.
If we change this,
Put everything back up.
It's waiting on MariaDB. Oh, maybe my one
second is maybe too quick. That's actually not
getting help in thing now.
Okay?
Oh, so it waits it waits initially for
that period before checking?
It will wait three of those, I believe.
Three. And so if we look at the
specs
So we have access to
oh, no. Here we go. So we got
test, we got interval,
and oh, yeah. We try. Okay.
I still can't bring up my projects.
Does MariaDB take more than fifteen seconds?
Do you need to give a parameter to
echo?
We shouldn't have to. No.
So it's still unhealthy. So that is actually
failing. Now I think the reason ah, yeah.
This will be Shell.
We can't specify that here. Okay.
We can copy this.
Oh, that's close. Actually, what we want is
test
and
we'll do bash
dot c
and then do echo dev piece of p
and report.
We'll do fix.
We're actually saying use batch because we have
to have a batch shell for for this
to work. I run a command, and then
that should give us the export that we
need.
Let's try that again.
Hey.
So we did see. I think it's a
question.
Our engine access failing. We'll fix that. I
don't know I don't know why that is.
So we didn't have the health check. They'd
have started in parallel. Right?
They would have started in parallel. Instead, we
were able to defer the start of the
p to p container and tell MariaDB was
actually out there.
Mhmm.
So NGINX failed because
that
was working.
Ah, so now so engine actually there we
go. There's the reason that we need the
the service starting.
Engine x cannot resolve upstream FPM connection PHP
because we got our dependencies a long way
around.
Yes.
What happens if you put them both
no.
It's like, like, dependency would fail.
But actually, what we're saying is PHP container
has to be started, which means the DNS
can be resolved before it interacts starts.
Now we'll get a completely healthy system.
Alright.
Happy with that.
So I ship this to production.
Okay.
So So it's like Heroku
Go or something.
No. We're gonna add a Docker file. And
we're gonna leverage
the build cache to make sure that we
can
we only ever do the composer install once
until we change composer dot JSON.
We also we're gonna use multi layers. So
there's a really frustrating thing at the PHP
images first.
If we do seven,
I'll find FPM.
We copy our composer dot JSON.
And when it's that working there, it's slash
app. It copies this to slash app, and
then I say run, compiler install.
This will not work
because the PHP images do not ship for
Composer.
I find that just ridiculous.
Like, people do not develop PHP beside Composer
anymore. Right? People do. People don't.
I
can give you names.
No. I don't want names. Just agree with
me. So
It's also a different organization. Right? Compose is
a
separate group of people.
I do understand that. It's it's it's not
part of the core PHP group and all
that. And also, to be honest, I don't
want Compose on my production image. So there's
that that has a a good thing to
it too. But
it makes you know, from a new person
that adopting containers and that's gonna work for
not having that available, it's probably annoying.
So what we're gonna do is we're gonna
say, let's have a development or build image.
Mhmm.
And I'm gonna copy from the composer image.
You mean copy. Right?
Not from
Got it.
I'm gonna do that. Then I'm gonna do
my seven
Alpine.
We want our build image. So from build
as
we'll call this
okay. I'm super cute. Call the top one,
like, base.
Base.
Good call.
From base as build.
You you knew what I was trying to
do? That is why you're here. And you
want the copy to be after build in
the in the build?
So this base image is just something that
I can use as a base for the
tools that I need. So I'm just adding
Composer to PHP.
Then in the build, I'm gonna copy and
compose the JSON. We'll do the installation.
Okay.
Can you I just probably thought that's kind
of agile.
How tight would you be about the versions
of everything? I know we'd
in real life, would you be
specifying a point release of PHP?
Yeah. I probably would.
I would. So do that.
Point.
And what what I like about this approach
is I can now use this
here.
But I've only got this defined once. You
know, there's there could very easily be a
version of PIVENCYR,
and then I wouldn't know what I'm doing.
So I could say build
Docker file. We don't need to specify because
it's in a default location. We need a
context.
And because this is multilayer, we need a
target, and I could say use the base
image to run this in dev.
If I really want to add extra stuff
to the dev version,
I could then extend base here
with dev, and I could add my dev
tooling. So and it's really common to say,
let's have a k add update and say
I need.
XD book.
XD book. Okay. I don't think that's an
app. But I don't think it's an alpha
and repository. Yeah. That that would work. So
And often in different environment variables and thing
I know you do that in the Compose.
So I would put the compose a copy
inside
just the build image because I don't want
that in my base.
If I'm gonna use base for development,
I will.
I don't want compose with my dev container
necessarily.
You're be running Composer in your image?
In your container?
For a local developer? Yes.
You're gonna, like well, that's not the way
I do it, but you're gonna be doing
exec Composer install
on the dev on the running dev container?
Okay. So this is this is where the
way I work is a bit different to
most people. So
some people will run composer install on their
local machine. I'm very much against that because
what happens there is you have to do
no
prereq
check something. There's a flag that you can
pass it to say, don't check for prerequisites
on the whole, like, PHP extensions. Get a
really good example.
What
I generally do is provide a make file
with a target called b shell, and that
puts me inside of the container, and I
work locally that way. Right.
Because
it's quite rare like you said, it's quite
rare to edit Compose JSON
at at at a certain point in the
project. You're not you're not really editing it
very often. I would rebuild
when I edited it. I I just sort
of remember to rebuild or do a make
file that rebuilds it.
Okay.
I think let's finish off this Dockerfile, and
then we'll show how that that step works
then. So
Do you wanna build it now? Check it
works? Yeah. So
we have we had just have a couple
of comments based on that conversation there. So
we've got one saying someone at Mark,
who says, I would run Composer and the
container. You may have multiple projects for multiple
Compose. Mean,
I would definitely run that container too, and
we get power team CI. I think that's
so important. Like, me running make bells locally
should be the same as my my CI.
There should be no distinction between those two.
Yeah.
Okay. So we got front bell as prod.
And now we want to do our production
image is gonna be
Base?
We didn't finish the build. Copy
everything
to that.
That's the And then
have so
we want our base.
F is gonna have a composure.
We're gonna use a dev image as our
base for building,
and then we use a base image for
production.
And what we do here is we'd say
copy all of our build artifacts
from build
like that.
Okay.
We can
Yeah. That work towards here, so it only
happens once.
So we no longer we no longer have
the
Composer
installer
on prod, is where I thought we were
going.
Got it. We've taken the Composer install out
of our production image.
And as far as command goes, I can't
remember the FPM syntax.
Why
why are you specifying it?
Why are you overriding the base images? Is
that a best practice you think?
K. You're right. I can just take that
here.
That's what I expect by default. Yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Okay.
So what does this mean?
On the on
line 13, you want one of them to
say do you want to copy Compose a
lock as well?
No.
I don't commit my lock fails. I I
would consider that a full path.
Because, like, people can the only reason people
the only reason you should commit your lock
fail is if you need item for the
builds.
And I'm shipping as a Docker container. I
don't need that.
I have the cache. I have the container.
I can reuse that cache. So if I
need to have a specific build where I
change something, I can then reference that. Commit
in a log file means that I'm not
gonna get automatic security updates.
It just removes a lot of things that
we've made slightly uncomfortable.
So it's because you're gonna be running your
CLN smoke tests
after the image is built anyway,
you don't need the guarantee that the image
is being built with a specific set of
dependencies.
I think committing the lock file comes from
that workflow where you're you're running CI in
just in PHP,
and you want that lock file to reflect
the set of dependencies that are gonna be
deployed.
You get that with
Docker. Right? If if you Yeah. I have
I have an immutable image that cannot change.
So I I I wouldn't commit my log
file. I I don't commit my log file
for any any code, any language.
I I would commit so the the rule
is I would commit my log file
if I'm gonna be testing based on the
log file and then separately deploying based on
the same log file.
So then the lock file's giving me that
sync, but the thing I tested is the
thing I'm deploying.
With doc,
you're not doing that separation. You're testing one
thing, and then you're moving it into into
prod.
So you don't need that extra synchronization
point.
Yep. Good point.
You.
Let me regain my train of thought. Okay.
So we we we
wanna build this now, and we wanna show
how we're leveraging the build cache so that
we don't Compose install
wasn't particularly slow in this project, and it
can take many minutes. Right? So we we
don't wanna do that unless that fail changes,
which is why we're being very specific about
the order that we copy all of this
time.
So if I do a build and I
target
build,
and I call this p I'll call it
Rawkode build beside of a class with the
PHP images that I have. I pass on
the build front. It's what I'm saying.
Tag not target.
Target.
Tag.
So
I'm targeting my build layer,
tagging it Rawkode build, and I've had go.
That's 7.4.
Okay. Let's take out the point, guys, and
just find that. I don't wanna have to
look that up,
and that should be based. Anyway
alright.
So we run this.
I got that wrong.
PHP
seven dash the FP and R plane.
Yeah. Maybe.
There we go.
No. That's totally not take too long.
Edge running the compose and resolve because this
is the first time
we
a brand new step.
Is this using build kit?
This is using build kit. Yes.
That's why I have a template. Potentially,
they're building parallel.
If I had multiple layers
where steps could be run-in parallel, yes, they
would run-in parallel. So, you know, we we
could we could show that working. We could
add another layer that ran our unit tests,
and those would run-in parallel with, say, something
that was doing our completion of our JavaScript
asset.
But if those wouldn't conflict.
That was what I was thinking. We this
compose a step build step could be running
and the MPM build step be running, and
then dev depend on both of them.
K. Good. Mhmm.
Now if we run this again,
it takes no time at all. Nothing has
changed. Nothing has nothing has to happen. Now
if we change the target to production,
the only thing that should run
is this.
We've got cached, cached, cached, cached,
the production step runs.
No. Why don't you make an edit to
index PHP?
Great idea.
In public.
Yeah.
So
I see million dollar change,
and we want to rebuild our production package.
And what the important thing that I I
believe you're trying to have me demonstrate here
is
let me build our Docker file.
Is it the only
so the way the cache of validation works
in Docker
is it starts at the top of this
file and it says, has this has anything
in this layer changed that would cause a
rebuild? No. Has anything in this line changed
that would cause a rebuild? No. Done. Done.
Done.
Has composed of updates unchanged?
No. Which means we don't have to run
Compose install. This copy has changed. We've just
modified the index dot PHP where we're calling.
So our cache is invalidated here,
which means everything below that's in the file
has to be run again.
If you change that fail, which means when
I run this, the compose of JSON
and the compose are installed do not need
to run.
Cool.
Perfect.
You can see our composer install and our
cash composer JSON did not work. It's very
fast. It just changed our code,
produced the image, and that was it.
Now if we change the composer dot JSON,
the composer install would run again,
and then every step will load out. Don't
think we need to cover that. I think,
hopefully, we'll explain that well enough that people
understand the build cache and why that's really
important for both of these. Mean, that was
ridiculously
fast. That's what I want.
And that's a good reason to have separate
build
targets
for for the PHP compose we install and
the NPM is
that you'll only be invalidating one of them
if if something changes.
So having a kind of diamond shape to
your targets
where two extend this one and then something
depends on both of them can really help
with builds because you the cache, like you
say, is sequential
Yep. In terms of layers. So splitting things
out and then copying the finished assets into
the final image can be really helpful. Oh,
yeah. Definitely.
And I guess it's also worth pointing out.
This is not unique to Composer or PHP.
Any any language with a package manager will
have a file like Composer. For Rust, it
would be cargo dot tunnel. For NPM,
node based stuff is package dot JSON.
This exact pattern works for all of those
languages frameworks and run time. And is it
based on the hash of the files?
It is. Yes. Yeah.
So it's the collective hash of the file
system.
So
because the only thing changing at this layer
is that one file, they only have to
check the hash of that one file, where
it's a whole directory like that. It would
be a cache of everything together as a
song.
Yeah.
And that and so it's important to also
include things in Docker ignore because here where
we're copying
everything into the image,
it's important anything that's gonna be a transient
file or change over time should be
Docker ignored. Right?
Very true.
Which maybe it is, one. Yeah.
So there are a lot of things here
that we would not expect to trigger a
rebuild,
And and the best way to handle that
Yeah.
So if if you're refreshing the cache locally,
you don't want that invalidating your
builds. Yeah. Or even just a readme. Like,
do I want a readme to cause a
rebuild with this application?
Yeah. And it also stops it being in
the image as well. Right? It does. It
will so the way this works is it
won't
if we look at this command, on the
end, we have this doc.
That's called the build context, and, like, Docker,
as sophisticated as it is, this is not
sophisticated.
That dot means that the Docker engine will
actually charge that that entire context, that directory,
and send that to the engine.
And that context is what ends up in
your image if you copy these things in.
So that's what if we have a dot
Docker ignore,
those files are stripped at the context stage
and never actually touch the Docker engine ever.
Does that make sense?
Yeah. Really.
Alright. So it all gets zipped up or
something. Right? And then transferred or tarred up?
Yep.
Yeah. There's there's I mean, we
we we work mostly on local machine for
the Docker engine and the context are are
available locally, but that's not always a case.
In fact, Docker expects that Docker engine to
be remote. In fact, Docker for Mac is
at the engine is actually on a VM.
So it's it's it's all tied up together
and sent over the pay under the VM
where it's then analyzed, extracted, and
Is there
we've not got any more questions.
So how are you for time?
I need to go in about ten minutes.
But you I mean, you could continue without
me.
No. Let's finish up in ten then. So
if you are watching and you've got any
questions on anything we've covered or anything we've
not covered that you want to know
or want us to explain, there is your
chat. This is it. You got ten minutes.
So
that gives me ten minutes to then shift
this image to Kubernetes.
Perfect.
So would you would you do a similar
build step for the NGINX just to get
the config file in there? Or would you
leave that to later?
No. I I wouldn't.
I wouldn't use a proprietary image for engine
x and Kubernetes.
I would use the official upstream ones, but
provide a volume down of the config for
config map.
So if it's just the config,
you'd always use a volume for that?
Yeah. I would I wouldn't build an image
for that.
I just don't think there would be any
value add on on doing so. Because remember,
I I then got to store those images
on my own registry somewhere
Mhmm. Which means I'll I don't have to
handle regular maintenance.
I have to rebuild it regularly so I'm
getting security updates, patches. I have to I
just create analysis of it. All that stuff
that I really don't wanna have to worry
about, but all I'm doing is modifying one
piece of configuration.
Yeah.
Okay. So
I use my opt directory for stuff like
this. I'm gonna create a Kubernetes,
and I'm going to have our PHP,
FPN
deployment.
Yeah. No.
And I have a nice
extension, which just kind of templates it all
for me.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, it's on the back. Come back to
the same. Yeah.
K.
Right.
The image
which I built was called Rawkode build. I'm
not gonna change that, so we could do
this.
I'm not gonna use any resource constraints for
the time being. I am gonna keep this
lame here because if I remove it, I
get a little bit squiggles.
And it's just telling me, hey. You probably
don't seem to deploy this into Kubernetes without
having resource constraints.
And
we're gonna say that our FTM runs on
port 9,000.
And that's it. It's good. Right?
Next, we need
our PPM. The next
private
So we'd
so you'd be building that image as part
of your CI pipeline.
The PHP
PHP, FPM, Apple, and the FPM.
Yeah.
So you wouldn't so is is that the
best practice? You don't build those things as
part of your Kubernetes
deployment process.
You
you develop things locally.
Something like CI then pushes an official image
somewhere after tests have passed,
and you're deploying off of that.
Yeah. I'd have something that then runs inside
of my Kubernetes cluster that would detect them
as a new image and do an automatic
roll out or deployment on it. Right. So
it's not pushing out to Kubernetes. It's
pushing through a registry and then Kubernetes
Yes. I would never have my CI pushed
to a Kubernetes cluster because then my CI
has to know that the cluster exists.
Yeah. It makes it really difficult to do
a femoral cluster. So if I wanna spin
up, like, a pre prod or a temporary
environment to do some testing Gotcha. I have
to build that into the CI step, and
I I always try to keep those
separate. So instead, what I'll have is
you push the image with a certain tagging
format that may say this is good for
production deployment, and then have many environments that
can pull that through. And and it's in
the test environment, which have a slightly different
tagging part. Right.
Okay. So
we're gonna call this
engine x.
We get default engine x image.
There we go. This
this is available on port 80.
Excuse
me.
Okay. Now we need to config that
For quickness,
I'm
just gonna copy this
from
here.
Normally, I wouldn't do that.
And I would have custom so there's a
tool called customized. It's a built in
the acute CPL.
And I can actually just create the conflict
map for you from a local file. So
that means I don't have a duplication. And
if you wanna read about that, it's on
customized.io.
You would go to docs
and
There's something there. You can tell to fill
in a file as a config.
It's definitely there, promise. So I think I
have to know one more.
Recall that's thedefault.com
because that's what the file is called.
Now that's changes. So we can either have
a service for PHP or I could do
something else.
Oh, in fact, I've got these as two
deployments, which I also wouldn't do. I guess
it doesn't matter for now. We could run
NGINX as a sidecar container in our APM.
What what do you wanna see? What's more
important to you?
Can you define sidecar container?
So in a pod in Kubernetes, a sidecar
container is generally what we would call any
container beyond the main container
that provides new functionality. So we could have
a deployment that runs at the end, and
then we could deploy a safeguard container. So
Nginx container next to it where they share
the same namespaces,
which means that they can communicate over local.
But let's let's do that because
yeah.
Let let's just do that. I think that
makes more sense. It's the that's how I
would do it in production. There's no point
of me changing from what I would normally
do. But
Do I have a
So we just add a new container. We
say we're gonna augment our PHP application with
engine x
Yeah. As a port.
And then in my configuration map here, I'm
actually just going to use Rawkode.
It's on port end side. They share the
same networking namespace.
That means I I don't even have a
network hop to go to get to it
either. But performing
cool.
The only thing I need to do now
is map this config map. Now this is
where I'm gonna forget the syntax, but let's
see what happens. We need to find a
volume called m g n a config,
which is that config map ref,
the name
of and I think I saw that I
did that. Yep.
Yeah.
So now it makes us available to me
and it can be consumed
here. That's volume mounts,
and we're gonna mount this to end of
x conflict d,
and we're going to mount
our
end of x
conflict.
Now I only want to mount a single
file.
Default. Yeah. I do that. Okay.
I think this may work.
It might work.
It may work. So what I'm gonna do
is that we're gonna shut down all the
Docker Compose stuff. My Docker Hub app is
already running Kubernetes.
Which is a tick box in there, isn't
it?
You just turn it on and it works.
Yeah.
You can see it's running, and it's just
under preferences.
Not the fastest application.
Yeah. Tick box. So I
can now do a quick control apply
dash
off Kubernetes.
And let's do the this one thing up
first.
Running.
So you can see we have two containers.
It's running. It's hopefully still running.
I'm gonna do it as port forward.
So this part
well, not import eighty eighty. But before I
do that, this will be broken.
And then
k.
We now have our two container pod
with NGINX
speaking to FPM
over local hosts and look at the response
time.
Drastically better than a PHP building web server.
And even better than the two container setup
locally as well. Drastically better.
Because of the lack of volume mapping. Right?
So all the files are inside the baked
container that you built?
Yeah. This is our node detection image. There's
no network traffic between NGINX and FPM, which
makes it a little bit faster. Even with
the two containers locally, they'd still be going
over a TCP connection. There would still be
a little bit of latency added there.
Right. But that's just really fast.
Awesome.
We had We've I have to leave at
this point.
It's been really good, David.
For I've I've learned a lot of things,
so thanks for inviting me.
No. You're thank you for joining me in.
Know, pleasure. Enjoy
the rest of your day. I'll do another
five minutes, and I'll finish up. And I'll
be I'll
watch the end when I get back.
Bye bye. See you later.
So we just had a a question that
I'll tackle there quickly is
does this mean I cannot scale engine x
and FBM independently?
So
that is correct.
When you're using multiple containers in a pod,
yeah, you scale them together.
If
for your own reasons, you don't want to
take that approach,
you would deploy them separately.
And and that would just mean,
you know, taking that out,
creating our FBM engine x deployment instead.
We call engine x.
We update the I mean, to that, I
can just
but
it does mean that my contact map has
to change because we are going over
the Kubernetes TCP stack now.
So instead, I'd be looking for something that
resolves to PHP,
which just means I have to expose
a service for our APM.
So I wanna call it PHP, and if
we look at the selector, I can see
that we have a label. It's all at
PHP FPN.
So I can do at PHP FPN,
and the service is going to map port
18,000.
And now our engine x, we can scale
that independently.
So we
can do a delete
deployment
PHP SPN.
I'm going to reapply all of our manifest.
Got something invalid in engine x.
Oh, yep. The volume, and I didn't stop
you across.
We apply all of those manifests,
and what we have now is that
we are PHP FPM is already running, engine
access to those can be scaled independently.
Fact, I could come into our
FPM
and modify the spec replicas.
I'll say two. And and, in fact, let's
say,
five. I don't know if these are all
scheduled based on my laptop constraints, but
we're maybe two NGINX and five FPM.
We run apply again.
And there we go. We've got five FPMs
to NZMX. Now what's different from the last
setup is that we now have a service
of PHP.
We can describe that service,
and we can see all the endpoints from
all of the bugs.
And if I port forward,
forward
engine x,
grab the first one,
Then
that works.
In fact, then going over the TCP stack
hasn't really modified
the time too much.
It's still really bad.
And that's it. So now you can choose
whatever fits your model. Because
I mean, the overhead of running NGINX is
relatively small. Running as a safeguard at APM,
I generally think it's okay. I'm not throwing
away too much resources. I'm gonna be consumed.
But if you do really want to deploy
and scale them separately, then that would be
how you do it.
Alright. I'm going to delete those resources.
They're all going away.
Next steps. So
I am going to
push this repository up. I've just forgotten where
that was or it just joined.
It is on getlab.com/rawkode/phpexamples.
The codes are from today will exist in
Kubernetes and Docker.
I do plan to do another session
either next week or the following week, where
we talk about using Kubernetes for local development
as well. We're just, you know, removing Docker
completely.
Because
it was kind of a couple of questions
early on,
I will also push a Laravel version of
this
some point today or tomorrow morning.
The only difference is gonna be between Laravel
and the slim framework stuff that we did
today. It's just that it will have a
little bit of extra
automation around handling that build step with the
Mode. Js stuff. The only thing that changes
is just the Docker file has another layer
that does the
the asset compilation,
and that's it.
There's not really a lot extra to add
there.
But I I wanna make sure that I
provide everything that's required. So
let's
do that. Thank you very much for joining
me. Hope that was useful, and feel free
to leave more comments. You can grab me
on Twitter if you want to ask any
questions afterwards. I'm always happy to help people
out. Feel free to get in touch, and
thank you for joining me. It's been good
fun. Have a nice day.